[Música]
[Aplausos]
u
ella es mi hija y cuando lo vio jugar
así me remonta a cuando con mis hermanos
jugamos con los potes de yogur y
construyamos pirámides altísimas llega
un punto que la torre superaba mi altura
y en puntitas de pie me acercaba a poner
un poste más arriba y sin querer
terminaba tirando todos los postes al
piso ese ruido ese ruido tan particular
lo tengo grabado entre risas con mis
hermanos
y es que mi hija no tenga otros juguetes
o que yo no las haya tenido sin embargo
jugar con esos potes tiene un nosequé
especial que nos hace divertir más
observaron en los cumpleaños cuando los
más chicos abren los regalos muchas
veces les llama más la atención el papel
envoltorio o la caja que el regalo en sí
la imaginación de los chicos convierte
esa caja en un mundo de posibilidades
puede ser un avión un auto un barco mil
cosas
para los más chicos esa caja no es
basura pasa a ser basura cuando los
adultos nos ponemos a ordenar y la
desechamos como tal
vieron las botellas de amor esas
botellas que se rellenan con plásticos
de un solo uso para mi hija son botellas
llenas de colores algo así como un
arcoiris de basura hasta llegar a ser
pines de bowling
lo curioso es que la llamamos botellas
de amor cuando en realidad están llenas
de basura saben por qué
porque cnr las es demostrar amor por
nuestro planeta
yo creo en las segundas oportunidades
porque no creer que la basura merece una
segunda oportunidad también
ese hábito que se instaló en mí de chica
marcó mi vida y mi vocación
hace años me dedico a darles segundas
oportunidades a aquello que otros
consideran basura
transformó materiales descartados en eco
productos
y luego porque creo en los negocios que
cambian el mundo con un impacto positivo
en el ambiente y en la sociedad
creo en una industria que transforma los
residuos para usarlos como materia prima
preservando así los recursos naturales
creo en las segundas oportunidades como
factor de cambios
la tierra no es una herencia de nuestros
padres es un préstamo de nuestros hijos
esto es un antiguo proverbio indio que
retomo gandhi quien murió hace más de 70
años
entonces porque nosotros heredamos esa
cultura del usar y tirar de lo
descartable
bueno en mi caso por suerte no fue así
porque tuve una madre y daba todo de
hecho teníamos y hoy en día aún existe
un sector en el garage en el cual
encontrar todos los reciclables
principalmente de envases y todo en
algún momento del año se reutilizaba
mediante juegos
entonces quien decide lo que es basura
quien define esto ya no sirve más
ya no sirve más para qué
no les hace ruido que algo lo que sea ya
no sirva para nada
en qué momento nuestros residuos pasan a
ser basura
cuando los descartamos como tal
si revisáramos con una mirada creativa a
nuestros residuos veríamos que en
realidad son recursos no existe la
basura la basura es algo que inventamos
que creamos nosotros en el momento que
decidimos etiquetar a los residuos como
tal
hay una campaña de concientización
ambiental que se denomina basura cero
sin embargo creo que para que realmente
haya cero basura tenemos que tomarnos el
tiempo de darle una segunda oportunidad
de reciclar
para poder desterrar así la palabra del
diccionario para nuestros hijos
cuando en casa se llena el tacho es
molesto visualmente
entonces como parte de la limpieza de la
casa sacamos esa bolsa llena de mugre
pero cuando la sacamos
a dónde va a parar
si hicieron esa pregunta alguna vez
la sacamos de nuestro cubículo pero
sigue estando en donde vivimos que es el
planeta
no desaparece por arte de magia
ignorarla no hace que no esté mirar para
otro lado no cambia la realidad lo que
está pasando
sin embargo de alguna forma logramos
aislarnos del problema
como si no fuese nuestra responsabilidad
yo no género ese plástico
el producto que compró bien en ese
plástico
en el momento que realizamos esa compra
esa decisión de compra es una elección
de apoyar y alentar a la empresa a que
siga haciendo las cosas como las está
haciendo
investigando un poco estoy segura que
podemos encontrar una alternativa más
seco amigable o preguntando en los
diferentes círculos sociales a los
cuales pertenecemos esté convencida que
alguien va a levantar la mano para
recomendarnos algo único producto
pero además se va a abrir una
conversación que va a informar e
inspirar a otros a realizar el mismo
cambio de hábito pero de no encontrar
esa alternativa básico amigable
creo que la respuesta está en separar en
reciclar en hacernos cargo de ese
material en el momento que lo compramos
no es más responsabilidad de la empresa
pasa a ser nuestra propiedad y nosotros
definimos su destino que puede ser un
vertedero
el mar
o una recicladora
la respuesta está en nosotros
una persona promedio genera más de un
kilo de basura por día
eso es aproximadamente un camión de
basura por minuto
sí alinearemos todos los camiones de
basura le daríamos más de una vuelta al
mundo
son 14 millones de toneladas de basura
las que se generan por año en el país y
la mitad de eso son plásticos que
lamentablemente terminan en los océanos
nuevamente la respuesta está en nosotros
procrastinar es una palabra que usó
mucho y que me parece que es muy clara
para graficar nuestra relación con la
basura
porque procrastinar no es más que
postergar las cosas para tener que
hacerlas más adelante y nosotros ya pero
que las tenemos un montón el hacernos
cargo abrir los ojos y
responsabilizarnos por lo que está
pasando
y por procrastinar las cosas están
empeorando porque el tiempo que nos
queda para reaccionar es casi nulo
y la tarea nos queda ahora de grandes
cuando entre miles de cosas que tenemos
en la cabeza encima tenemos que lograr
un cambio de hábitos
con lo que cuesta cambiar hábitos
cuando uno es chico cualquier cosa la
puede convertir en un juego ahora anda
decirle a tu hijo adolescente que es
divertido separan los residuos según el
tacho de color que corresponda
en cambio si fuese un hábito heredado
algo que funciona en forma automática
casi sin pensar funcionaría
se aprendió así y se aplica
sabemos que los cambios de hábitos
llevan tiempo y para muchos un gran
esfuerzo sin embargo hoy quiero
invitarlos a empezar a empezar por algo
por más chico que sea ir paso a paso y
comprometerse a ser ambientalistas
aunque sean imperfectos
dejar la queja para pasar a la acción y
ser parte de la solución
qué impacto se generaría si cada uno de
nosotros se compromete a ser un
ambientalista imperfecto
rechazando o reduciendo nuestro consumo
estamos previniendo que se genere ese
material de materias primas vírgenes
separando nuestros residuos y reciclando
estamos potenciando a la industria
recicladora de la cual se pueden proveer
las empresas para sus procesos de
producción
en el momento que los materiales se
ingresan en el circuito comercial e
industrial
nosotros podemos ahorrar insumos agua
energía y eso hace que los materiales
reciclados sean más económicos que los
materiales vírgenes
entonces la pregunta no es se puede
la pregunta es cómo
comportando podemos reducir nuestros
residuos casi a la mitad porque se
calcula que el 50 por ciento de nuestros
residuos son orgánicos
un 20 por ciento es papel y cartón
un 14% son plásticos
12% metales
y otros materiales recurrentes son
electrónicos y vidrios
entonces viendo esto podríamos darle
casi todo una segunda oportunidad si
separamos los residuos y reciclarlos
cuestiona su consumo pero cuestionó
también lo que consideras basura
entender cómo está interconectado todo
es darnos cuenta del poder que tienen
nuestras acciones y nuestras decisiones
por más mínimas que sean no sólo estamos
colaborando por un mundo mejor sino que
estamos inspirando porque siempre hay
alguien mirando formas que no nos demos
cuenta sobre todo nuestros hijos ellas
siempre están invitando nos
si no muestro a mi hija un frasco vacío
y limpio y mermelada y le pregunto qué
es esto
estoy segura que ninguna de sus
respuestas va a ser es basura
yo creo en las segundas oportunidades
y me encantaría que hoy
a partir de esta charla ustedes también
empiecen a crear en las segundas
oportunidades
y se comprometan a ser ambientalistas
aunque sean perfectos y empezando por
algo paso a paso
cambiemos nuestros hábitos por un mundo
mejor
[Música]
[Aplausos]